when our body is infected by a pathogen
then our immune system kicks in and try
to protect our body from that pathogenic
attack and just after the pathogen has
invaded the body it would secrete their
antigens or immunogen's against which
our body secretes antibodies so
definitely after a pathogenic invasion
the serum antibody concentration is
increasing and it's a nice biomarker to
understand that there is a pathogenic
invasion now let's look at the same
thing in a graphical format let's say
our body is invaded by the pathogen and
we are looking at the antibody
concentration in the serum and in x-axis
we are looking at days after which the
invasion happened this white arrow de
marks the time of pathogenic innovation
so roughly about 10 days the IgM
antibody concentration in the blood
really increases and after almost 20
days IgG against that specific antigen
is increasing so after that I mean you
can clearly see there is a lag phase
between the pathogen invasion and rise
of the anti antibody concentration why
is that lag but this immune response is
known as primary immune response whereas
in case of secondary immune response
which is followed by a another
pathogenic innovation around the
antibody level increase is pretty quick
but let's look at the primary immune
response first in the primary immune
response there is a lag phase and let's
try to understand why there is a lag
phase between a pathogen invasion and
antibody level increasing so let's say
this individual is infected by this
pathogen and the pathogen came from a
rusty nail which is actually poked
inside the skin of this individual now
these pathogens actually secrete lot of
factors and a lot of
engines which are actually recognized by
the dendritic cells and the macrophages
now this dendritic cell and the
macrophages engulf the pathogen after
that the pathogen is degraded inside the
Hindoos ohms and in do lysosomes some
part of them is actually displayed on
the surface of these antigen presenting
cells on class 2 MHC now after it
recognized the pathogen it also secretes
alarming molecules such as inflammatory
cytokines which would attract other
cells such as other macrophages and the
dendritic cells which are nearby to the
location also these dendritic cell which
has recognized the pathogen would
eventually migrate towards the lymph
node now lymph node which is situated
all over the body is actually an army
base camp because it has T cell area and
B cell area so inside the lymph node
there are specific regions where T and B
cells reside now after that these
dendritic cells would allow activation
of the T cells and the T cells would
allow the activation of the PC else when
the b-cells is activated quickly it
forms a plasma cell now plasma cells
secrete then and their antibody into the
bloodstream which can immediately act on
the pathogenic antigen now otherwise the
B cells migrate to the terminal cell
migrate to the B cell follicular zone
and in there they amplify I'm amplify
and proliferate to form the germinal
Center and eventually they can be
differentiated into the plasma cells or
they can also die or they can become a
memory cell now most of the cells which
are activated by the T helper cell or
independent of T helper cell would
undergo cell cycle and thereby they
would divide and grow in number but soon
after the first exposure is done and the
pathogen is neutralized by the antibody
then most of them would die and few of
them would leave and they are known as
the memory B cell
now the memory B cell would have a
memory of which pathogen has invaded the
body and what type of antigen it has
encountered and what type of against
what type of antigen it hasn't made the
antibody so next time whenever there is
a similar pathogenic invasion it would
create the same isotype of that antibody
and really quickly by that time isotype
switching has happened so most of the
prevalent form of antibody at this point
of time is IgG not the IgM in short what
we see in the secondary immune response
the lag phase is pretty low because
already the memory b-cell had an idea
that what pathogen has invaded the body
what type of antigen it produced so it
can quickly make the antibodies now
first there is a IgM mediated response
but here the heightened response is
actually triggered by IgG because i
isotype switching has happened in these
cells and that is why the lag phase is
pretty lower compared to the initial
pathogenic invasion or initial immune
response and this kind of immune
response which is mostly mediated by IgG
and mediated by memory b-cells this is
known as the secondary immune response
now
the key player of the secondary immune
response is a b-cell but have you ever
wondered that where does this memory
b-cells come from
so about memory b-cell I will have a
separate video I would recommend you to
watch that video but if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you